[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
care less and I am so happy to bring you
this episode because this is my how can
I say it revenge on an MCU episode I
feel like there's a level of disrespect
and it's all handed out to my boy Clint
over here
Clinton Francis Barton better known as
Hawkeye this is side Schultz exclusive
Hawkeye and let me tell you man
I'm so pleased to bring this statue to
you but let me tell you why I feel like
the MCU has disrespected Hawkeye first
that's not it just that's not overlooked
let's address the fact that oh boy went
missing and one major movie and
everybody was left to say what was he
doing what was going on what's
everything with him type of thing but
let's rewind all of this let's go to the
comic books let's get down to why I feel
that this character is disrespected
first of all let me tell you something
you see how big this dude is you see how
robust and strong he is I'm just saying
mr. Reiner just really doesn't mess it
up to this guy statue this guy at one
point in time impersonated Captain
America just to get by an episode not
only is Hawkeye an accomplished Archer
marksman tactician Acrobat he's a great
at fencing he was trained by the
swordsman and the swordsman is the
premier weapons Smith when it comes to
blades in the Marvel Universe it's not
much more I can say as far as his power
because he's at peak human condition at
all times I always thought that he was
an outstanding example of how a villain
becomes a hero he first debuted in tales
of suspense I think it was 57 57 or 53
and he was a villain and I think
everybody wanted him to be a good guy so
bad because when he debuted it brought
back up again because he debuted in
tales of suspense when he came back
again and avenges 16 he became it was a
long story long troll but he became a
part of the New Avengers and also he is
so versatile he has many aliases that he
I would buy many forms of him the
character because he's such a likable
character he was Goliath
[Music]
the golden Archer and a Captain America
book and also roni roni
you got a chance to see Ronan in the MCU
for a very brief stint and I believe
that that that character was misused
I believe that you didn't get a build-up
to why he was running I mean you got a
small synapses you thought it was
supposed to be okay
I think they always didn't maul MCU
didn't always understand exactly where
he fit in the universe to be honest with
you you know you have some battling with
gods and super soldiers and here he is
this regular guy but they found the
place for the Black Widow which she was
underused as well you know um this guy
in the comic books money money when he
first got his own book all right his
first book was Hawkeye and I remember
reading and I'm like man I was so
enthused by the book because of what
he's able to do he it's used to drive
this the Skycycle
and it was just a very good read you
know he is not much things that he can't
do so the fact that he's so versatile
and in MCU he's so limited that kind of
you know frustrated me to death you only
thought that he was the arrow guy and
it's not just that you know seriously
acrobatic alright um so you say going
into this you also cut it with some
weird love triangle that you had with
the Black Widow which was never real in
the comic books his love interest is
Mockingbird and they formed the West
Coast Avengers
yes Hawkeye was in charge of his own
team do you know how huge that is like
he's not a sideshow dude he's not a um
ha ha ha no pun intended sideshow is
easy is not a second-rate character
two-bit character he's a preemie a
character an MCU and it won't none an
MCU in Marvel Comics so for him to have
this backseat role
I understand you have stronger
characters but come on man remember when
y'all saw ant-man grow really big and he
was giant man well in the books he did
them he was Goliath for a while he was a
strong man on the Avengers he was the
muscle so again you say to yourself why
couldn't he find a better role why they
couldn't work him in a little bit better
I think they tried to clean it up and
what was it the infinity war and I just
thought that they didn't clean it up
properly first I love that costume the
fact that he was nothing and it's
constant I know and look a little corny
but come on man you're Captain America
in his corny soup yet throwing his corny
suit even with the helmet
you had Iron Man and his cloning suit
but she put him in his pointy suit which
I love so let's get this straight first
of all a lot of you guys he's gonna ask
me who came first green arrow or Hawkeye
isn't he a ripoff okay in a sense he is
a ripoff because her green arrow came
out two decades before he did but
when he debuted when Hawkeye debuted he
was a villain never debuted as a hero he
was converted into a hero because
everybody loved him so much
had to get him his own book right so now
he's a hero who would win in a fight
Hawkeye will win in a fight Hawkeye is
not as reliant on just arrows and trick
arrows as green arrow is Hawkeye is a
supreme tactician he can turn anything
into a weapon like bullseye he is a very
lethal hero the fact that you guys don't
get a chance to see him in all his glory
kind of sucks but he are going kos I'm
bringing you this bad boy right here the
reason why I got this statue is because
again let me tell you I can't understate
it more or overstated more to you
because he's been understanding for so
long I can't overstate it more to you
that he is a key part to the Avengers
without him let's say you take on
Captain America on the field he can
actually step in that role as a
tactician and map out exactly how to win
the fight and win the battle actually
give commands and lead so Hawkeye is a
supreme leader and also a great fighter
the statue statue in his action poled
look at that dynamic pose this is one of
the first dynamic poses that sideshow
has put together I known the base I'm
kind of disappointed in the face the
base is really bland you have a black
cylinder at the bottom and you have the
rock sticking out but for in fact if it
works in that manner but then you also
have the dynamic poles with the arm
as he's just finished shooting the arrow
and him holding the bow and you have
more bows in his quiver and it's
mixed-media as you can see his toga part
that hangs in between his legs that's
made out of material and it hangs
perfectly you can actually pose it a
little bit so you can have a leg blowing
in the wind or whatever but the dynamic
pose of it alone has sold it on me and I
needed to have him help finish off my
Avengers collection
I can't stay this enough XM did one but
I went with the sideshow one because I
felt that the sideshow one actually
captured the Hawkeye essence even the
the portrait shows action the hope
portrait is action wise the hands is
action opposes action the leg being bent
he just shot the arrow is action and if
you want a statue that just exhibits
action and you're a fan of horrified I
suggest you hunt this statue down you're
gonna pay a pretty penny for them if you
can get them and also double check your
boxes make sure that the bows don't come
broken I know a lot of them they they
propose is broken so be careful when
purchasing off the eBay all right but um
that's the only way you're gonna get it
you're not getting them from sideshow
right now this is came out a long time
ago but it's new to me and I loved the
statue and he's gonna be exhibited in my
Avengers section so thank you guys it's
a part in the video and I tell you like
follow subscribe also go to Lords of
gaming dotnet and we have all the
information on everything the new trade
shows the new Kos the old Kos combat
talk with the king the last world will
Cognito on Eve on ttis you can get all
that loot oh shoot
trust me you don't want to miss that
self especially with the new DLCs about
to drop and the new games coming out you
do not want to miss that you don't want
to miss the reviews with Lord addict
Lord addicts reviews right now are
creeping up there to be some of the top
reviews that you can get and I'm gonna
tell you right now no one can finish a
hard game like that man can so if you
need all the information for the Lords
of game and dot net we got you now stick
around so you can see this statue and
all this glory there's a ton of pitches
you can listen to the music and don't
have to hear me talking
see you next week when I give you
somebody that is pretty strong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]